na sind sie auch so erleichtert am 20
märz endet corona also corona geht
weiter aber wir machen halt nicht mehr
mit pünktlich zum frühlingsanfang
entfallen alle tief greifenden
schutzmaßnahmen so beschlossen von der
bund länder runde am mittwoch ab sofort
dürfen sich wieder mehr als zehn
geimpften oder gelesene treffen es war
längst überfällig
warte mal das ist doch umgehend das habe
ich bei telegramm gelesen sekunde so
stimmt ja wie beim adventskalender geht
jetzt alle paar tage ein neues
lockerungs türchen auf und dann kommt
endlich der eine tag an dem alles gut
wird soeben hat uns diese meldung
erreicht deutschland
[Musik]
jetzt wo das virus die amigos gehört hat
geht es wahrscheinlich sogar freiwillig
grüße freedom zurückgeben das ist das
motto zumindest solange sich die lage in
den krankenhäusern weiter entspannt und
keine neue mutanten um die ecke gucken
also ist der einzelhandel wieder für
alle zugänglich und schon ab dem vierten
märz geht es aber vorab mit fetten beats
auf den dancefloors in den clubs oder
wie man die jungen leute das dann eben
in schritt zwei ab dem vierten märz die
lockerungen und regierungen für
gastronomie und hotellerie lockerungen
für diskotheken und clubs in andere tanz
lustbarkeit
tanz lustbarkeiten so heißt das übrigens
auch bei zdf betriebsfeiern wenn dj
doppelherz auflegt und weil sich die
bund länder runde treu bleibt haben
natürlich auch in dieser woche wieder
diverse länderchefs eigene regeln für
ihre kleinen fürstentümer verkündet
tradition hat aber kommt das sind
fußnoten freuen wir uns einfach auf den
20 märz den freedom day das wird
bestimmt voll emotional
im zdf deutschland verabschiedet dass
gruner virus mit dem großen
zapfenstreich
ein abend voller persönlicher
erinnerungen
wenn sie ihre taschentücher raus wenn
die bundeswehr den virus zum abschied
drei persönliche musikwünsche erfüllt
niemals geht man so ganz gefolgt von du
hast die impfpflicht vergessen
[Musik]
und als weiterer mutmacher zum schluss
hat eine mutante aus marokko wo die
konnte
wir sehen uns im herbst bleibt gesund
und weg mit der meisten pflicht der
große gewinner zapfenstreich am frieden
bay city
achja hust zum abschied leise cupid ich
fürchte es gibt ein wiedersehen trotzdem
ist es richtig jetzt auf mehr
eigenverantwortung der bürger zu setzen
ob das auch beim thema masken gilt da
gehen die ampel meinung allerdings noch
sehr weit auseinander wolfgang kubicki
zum beispiel findet selbst die masken
pflicht sollte zum zwanzigster märz
fallen in mecklenburg vorpommern fällt
sie schon anfang märz in den schulen
während anderswo sogar reguliert wird
was man unter der maske tragen darf zb
an der uni greifswald für ein
medizinstudium nicht sicher genug hat
jetzt die uniklinik kreisweit
entschieden und ihren studenten ein
vollbad verbot verordnet den männlichen
studenten war eine mail ins haus
geflattert auf der zu sehen ist was noch
erlaubt und was ab nun verboten ist was
wieso nur den männlichen studenten finde
ich diskriminieren okay aber kleinere
werte bleiben ja weiter erlaubt der hier
zum beispiel geht so jetzt wage ich mal
eine ganz frische prognose wir werden
auch diesen sommer wieder nicht nutzen
um uns auf den pandemie herbst
vorzubereiten
warum so schönes wetter zu viele wahlen
da wirst du dich als politiker nicht
unnötig unbeliebt machen also wird es
bei der großen deutschen impflücken
bleiben und bei der noch größeren
datenlücke es ist unfassbar peinlich auf
wie viele fragen wie auch im dritten
corona ja keine antwort haben vor allen
dingen auch so einfache basis zahlen wie
viele krankenhausbetten haben wir wie
viele sind davon frei wie viele cupid
patienten liegen tal jeden tag da und
vor allen dingen auch wieviel
pflegekräfte kümmern sich eigentlich um
die patienten ich weiß es zu wenig war
einfach wir wissen ja noch nicht mal wie
viele leute bei uns wirklich geimpft
sind
christa würde da enorm helfen und ja das
geht auch daten sicher wie zivilisierte
nachbarländer seit monaten vormachen
wird trotzdem nicht kommen genauso wenig
wie die allgemeine impfpflicht
vielleicht gibt es noch eine 550
wahrscheinlich nicht mal das die union
spricht zum beispiel nur noch von imf
mechanismus weil das wort pflicht so
hässlich klingt allerdings dürfe dann
auch nicht rumheulen wenn es im herbst
mit variante xviii immer läuft ja aber
wie soll man denn so eine impfpflicht
ohne register kontrollieren ja ganz
einfach ich sage ihnen wir holen unsere
ehemaligen gez fahnder aus der rente sie
wissen schon diese leute die früher in
mülltonnen gewählt haben um anhand einer
alten hör zu zu erkennen dass jemand
eben doch einen fernseher hat genau das
machen wir jetzt wieder und wenn ihr zum
beispiel ein altes kochbuch von attila
hildmann finden
ungeimpfter überführt
man müsste die gez dann natürlich
umbenennen in bill und melinda gates
foundation
jetzt geht's
gestern ist übrigens die geplante
bundestagsdebatte über die impfpflicht
ausgefallen und leider gibt es im ganzen
februar nur eine sitzungswoche wegen ich
wünschte es wäre ein witz karneval ja
allein daran erkennt man schon wie
wichtig uns die impfpflicht ist wo wir
gerade beim karneval sind selbst der ist
bei uns plötzlich wieder möglich laut
corona schutz verordnung dürfen kommunen
dafür sogenannte brauchtums zonen
ausweisen im grunde so eine art gehege
für das kontrollierte die sau rauslassen
dazu begrüße ich ulrich von heesen er
sitzt seit über 70 jahren im elferrat
der kölner karnevalsgesellschaft der
fidelen leberzirrhosen ulrich erklären
sie mir doch mal die brauchtums zone ach
ja einem
ostwestfalen kerne werden
ich versuch's mal so passau halle feiern
oben ohne in der kölner brauchtums zone
laufen knapp dann ohne pause nur welches
uli sitzt zu hause
erstens die tusch maschine kommt sofort
weg zweitens wir ihn hier in der sendung
ganz normal aber ganz normal
da sind wir dabei dat is prima
viva colonia
wo sind denn alle wir haben immer noch
kein publikum wegen corona also ich
merke schon sie sind jetzt wirklich ganz
verblödet oder was die stadt köln hat
sich letzte woche zu einer einzigen
großen brauchtums zone erklärt mit der
begründung man könne zitat kaum bereiche
oder fädeln finden in denen keine
karneval feiern stattfinden heißt
übersetzt also für domany sie
besteht eine offizielle carnevals
pflicht und zwar auch für dich
freundchen noch
ist jetzt ganz alleine weg biete die
schale pferde piste ich denke überhaupt
nicht daran
wir befinden uns hier in einer
brauchtums ohne oder damit heißt ja gut
top entscheidung in ganz köln karneval
zu erlauben ich meine wir haben hier
doch am 11.11 eindeutig bewiesen dass
wir corona konform feiern können abstand
lustige masken da stimmt einfach alles
außerdem muss man ja in der brauchtums
ohnedies mal geimpft genesen und
gebuchter zahlen drinnen sogar plus
negativer test ja aber nur wenn sie drin
und karneval feiern wer einfach nur was
ist der brauch kein test super simples
ist der super simpel wer soll das denn
kontrollieren in dem ganzen besoffenen
chaos jetzt trinkgeld aus dieser
geplagte stadt hat weiß gott genug
durchgemacht ich sage nur weiter fasst
nach 2021
gähnende leere wir sehen einzelne
personen die hier unterwegs sind die
masken pflicht geht auch gewunken wird
ab und zu noch mal hier sehen wir auch
einen jecken auf der bank mit seinem
handy spielt er sich selbst gerne weil
sie doch vorher hat die rote nase auf
der weißen maske
solche bilder dürfen nie wieder von
deutschem boden aus gehen und alle ja
wenn
das umweg kommt dann schon mal alle
parat und mentoring durch von hessen
[Applaus]
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liebsten mit - wollt dann abonniert
jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller